compréhension
qu'ont création et crée la famille shaw
la can est arrivé au pays il y a à peine
plus d'un an d'origine arménienne elle a
vécu en jordanie avant de choisir le
québec
tous ont suivi un premier cours de
français avant d'immigrer mais malgré ça
l'intégration ne posait tout repos la
france c'est une très belle mais le
grand mère c'est un peu difficile le
premier jour j'ai dû recréer
toute la famille s'est mise à
l'apprentissage intensif du français
depuis maggie et arabes vont à l'école à
temps plein tandis que hyères chaud et
choïgou suivent des cours de français
quotidien
faciliter notre vie ici
carlos carmona qui travaille dans le
milieu de la francisation depuis une
quarantaine d'années constate que les
immigrants qui parlent déjà un peu
français ou qui viennent de pays où la
langue française jouit d'une certaine
notoriété ont tendance à apprendre plus
facilement certains pays d'europe de
l'est il ya des pays en amérique du sud
aussi où les français à une certain
prestige les gens issus de ces pays
viennent ici au québec et ils ont une
tendance haussière de s'intégrer à la
société en français car apprendre la
langue une fois installé ne se fait pas
sans peine selon une étude récente
produite pour l'office québécois de la
langue française les deux tiers des
adultes qui ne parlait pas français à
leur arrivée ne le parlent toujours pas
dix ans plus tard le projet doit 96
créer un nouvel organisme francisation
québec mais il ne modifie pas les
critères de sélection des immigrants or
pour de nombreux experts entendus ces
dernières semaines en commission
parlementaire l'avenir du français
repose autant sinon plus sur une
politique d'immigration renforcée que
sur un durcissement de la loi 101 la
forte présence
d'immigrants de culture française de
l'ong française qui connaissait le
français au préalable avant d'émigrer au
québec a été un facteur déterminant dans
l'amélioration
de le pouvoir d'attraction du français à
l'instar d'autres experts charles
castonguay estime que le gouvernement
doit accorder plus d'importance à la
connaissance du français dans la
sélection des immigrants une mesure qui
a fait ses preuves autant sinon plus à
son avis que la loi 101 dans les années
70 avec les réfugiés haïtiens qui
fuyaient le régime duvalier ou encore
les vietnamiennes par exemple qu'ils
fuyaient la guerre au vietnam c'était
des francos europe et ils ont
effectivement la majorité des migrants
de ces cohortes là ce sont franchisés
dès le début des années 70 ça vient voit
avec la loi sont à quelques personnes de
lire sur le terrain on aimerait pouvoir
offrir des cours de français plus
rapidement dans plusieurs organismes de
francisation les cours commencent en
janvier avril juillet et octobre de
chaque année les immigrants qui arrivent
dans l'entrefaite doivent trop souvent
attendre au trimestre suivant pour
commencer leur parcours de francisation
c'est au début que ça s'est passé et il
faut pas que la personne il faut pas que
la personne peut se faire attiré par
surtout de ceux qui parlent français à
leur arrivée ont plus de chances de
rester au québec à long terme les
immigrants admis entre 2010 et 2019 86 %
de ceux qui parlaient français seulement
habité toujours au québec en 2021 contre
seulement 61 % dessus qui ne parlait
qu'anglais donc apprendre le français
c'est très important que les personnes
puissent commencer un processus de
francisation le plus tôt possible la
famille ch la cannelle est bien
déterminée à poursuivre son
apprentissage du français le français
sert le langue officielle du québec et
sans connaître le français la vie va
être un peu difficile hockey au québec